[Música]
i
hola que tal buenas tardes
tengo 18 minutos beber rápido para
intentar aprovecharlos hoy engancho
gonzález oramas soy fotógrafo
profesional desde hace 30 años
tengo una presentación que ver si aquí
está
voy a darles de mi pasión realmente
estoy enfocado mi profesión y mi pasión
y me dedico a hacer fotografías el
título de la charla es fotosensibles e
intentaré desarrollarlo porque realmente
lo que lleva haciendo toda la vida es
ver cómo esto aquí llevo toda la vida
haciendo fotografías de eventos y
espectáculos en el cual uso en películas
de mucha sensibilidad básicamente y a la
gente en transmitir sensaciones
vengo del mundo analógico como hacer
pase al mundo digital y ahora no estamos
el mundo digital que estamos en esta
edad
soy fotógrafo de concierto al hablar de
mi vida ha hecho 2000 conciertos tres
mil conciertos siempre es felicidad
a todos los que han pasado
por canarias aquí tengo una selección de
la selección algunos de los personajes
que ha hecho por él ha hecho muchísima
gente podría ponerles
fotos de concierto y de ópera
agricultura pero no lo voy a hacer
ni trabajo básicamente consiste en
hacer eventos en marcarlos transmitir
sensaciones ubicarlos contextualizarlo y
todo eso se hace a base de películas
antes sensibles a cámaras muy sensibles
y buscar objetivos y planos muy
espectaculares que reciban buenas
sensaciones
esto por ejemplo las fotos estación de
diciembre en el auditorio alfredo kraus
tres conciertos de eventos diferentes
esto también en diciembre the sun
santana trabaja por muchas
organizaciones
[Música]
espectáculos pero en mi pasión verdadera
empieza cuando dejo hacer mis trabajos
profesionales en todo empieza desde mí
desde mi ventana yo vivo en la línea
marítima y en mi facebook empieza a
hacer fotos de lo que veo en mis
ventanas
esto es una foto de mi casa empieza a
hacer fotos de amaneceres y empieza a
colgarlas
por ejemplo en casa también es como digo
yo la mezcla entre el símbolo de repsol
y el pp cuando quería cuando quería
traernos el petróleo no voy a meterme
muchos jardines pero ahí lo dejo y
entonces empiezo a hacer este tipo de
fotos y empiezo a colgarlas esto es una
línea marítima un amanecer
después también tú eres teniendo el sol
empiezo hacer este tipo de fotografías
un poco sin conciencia
y empezará a compartirse y tener cierto
éxito esto fue la famosa nube roja del
año pasado se vieron también desde mi
casa
la luz es todo desde mi casa también un
día es esta foto de hace 200 años como
un velero una gaviota y fuerteventura
también detrás
y al atardecer de un día es curioso en
fuerteventura serie muy fácilmente al
amanecer al atardecer es difícil verlo y
hace 200 años
al día siguiente dos horas después hizo
una foto de el siglo actual como la luz
marca todos elementos también pero la
luz marca todo
[Música]
toda la información
sigo haciendo fotos desde mi ventana
amaneceres por ejemplo esto es un rayo
verde
no sé si conocen lo que es el rayo verde
bueno hay una novela de julio verne que
es en cierta parte del mundo antes de
que nazca depende las condiciones que
haya se ve un rayito verde que es lo que
se ve justo antes de que salga el sol
nos dice que cuando dos personas ven un
rayo verde tendrán amor eterno
esto también sigue siendo desde mi casa
empiezo a compartir fotos y todo el
mundo hasta una página profesional
reticente y seguí haciéndolo y empecé a
a trabajar otras cosas siempre en
condiciones de luz muy extremas
relacionado con mi mundo profesional
todo
son momentos de luz muy concretos
es muy crítico en el riesgo está el
éxito de las cosas sencillas la foto
normal
del mediodía no tiene ningún sentido
todo lo que busco yo siempre es un
instante de luz curioso los riesgos por
ejemplo es un tema muy recurrente en mi
fotografía de anteriores ricos a juan
esto por ejemplo es el disco de san
antonio desde mi ventana de nuevo
al final viendo el piso esto por ejemplo
es curioso este es el disco de san
antonio
la foto es parece que tanto las
encendidas y realmente están apagadas y
el sol en el primer rayo del sol del día
que iluminan las ventanas y encienden
las las casas todas las casas están en
el mismo plano
orientada entonces un día del año que
pasa de esto yo empiezo a hacer estas
cosas sin saber sin tomar conciencia que
voy aprendiendo más de cómo funciona el
sol
y la nube yo soy un pasado de rosca por
ejemplo
este es un 25 de diciembre un amanecer
cuando todo el mundo se va de marcha tal
yo me dedico a hacer estas cosas y ese
era un 25 de diciembre un gallo que se
retiraba después hacer su trabajo
en san juan no
esto en las fotos hace poco hace un mes
y medio desde intentar también que esta
opción es bueno
desde hoy en la casa de la luna
poniéndose al amanecer no san roque los
riesgos de un tema que me apasionan
necesito encontrando fotografías
casuales que no sin buscarlas esto por
ejemplo en agaete una puesta de sol el
sol verde apunta del teide y un señor
que no sabemos quién es pero nos invita
a reflexionar sobre su vida nos en su
soledad
en el año 2015 tengo la oportunidad de
irme a hacer un eclipse de súper luna en
este vídeo
en doce horas subir dos veces a la punta
del teide y esto por ejemplo es al
atardecer
el atardecer según cómo va la luna la
adquisición del eje en el teide siempre
proyecta una sombra de al amanecer al
atardecer y la sombra del teide iba al
encuentro de la luna lo que vemos aquí a
la izquierda es el observatorio de
diseño
en tenerife no
estos son ese día todo lo que dice una
experiencia increíble la verdad 20
minutos todo el eclipse al amanecer del
día siguiente volví a subir a la punta
del tdi esto es la misma escena del
anterior al atardecer al amanecer al
amanecer
la sombra del teide proyectada sobre el
volcán del pico viejo entre dice y
buscando el encuentro de la luna ya de
clase de la gomera no
la luna bueno
esta foto es marcó un antes y después en
mis fotografías más rápido
esta ley es un día desde este cargo
la cuelgo y es la locura se comparte
cinco mil y pico en 24 horas llegar a
500 mil personas desde mi facebook lo
que hace el whatsapp
lo que la gente acá por ahí nuevo tengo
controlado
es el
la pantalla de gáldar ahora alineado con
el tejido enumerado y al amanecer antes
de haber hecho esta foto estaba llegando
a hacer la foto
hice esta foto que si se fijan no está
perfectamente alineado en la montaña con
con el teide
pero cómo estaba la vida de esta foto es
que en la luna vemos reflejados los
observatorios del cliente tipo de diseño
del teide están dentro de la de
casualidad esto no son cosas que no hay
buscado sino que me las encontré en 19
minutos
desde las 10 am y me gusta mucho
contextualizar la fotografía que tiene
dónde está el eclipse si no tenemos una
referencia puede ser cualquier lado
entonces lo que hice es el montaje esto
para ver toda la secuencia el eclipse y
aquí por ejemplo es una especie de luna
roja al amanecer no aquí vemos una fase
de ese eclipse y también se ve el
piquito de la sombra del teide que vimos
antes
arriba
esto es el eclipse del año pasado en
verano de son un cruce que hubo este
verano también es rico en todo hay un
evento astronómico hay que planificarlo
buscarlo y aquí el problema estaría
calima antes de buscar un sitio donde se
viese fuera complicado arriba es más
fácil no hay menos contaminación que en
la costa y éste es el gran pasado
sigo haciendo fotos de lunas y tal es el
día del atentado de charly en francia
es la catedral de las palmas con la luna
morante será un cruce de culturas
estrellas cielos no voy a hablar mucho
en canarias un sitio muy conocido que
desde la ventana del nublo agujereada no
es la portada una foto de éste para un
2011 desde un grupo del semi juglar
no tengo una crisis
bueno con todas estas cosas que me
empiezo encontrar ya empiezo a entender
un poco cómo funciona y empieza a
planificar las noches o los programas
para planificar
aventuras nocturnas una serie de fotos
yo no sería el foto de cemer y que son
dos fotos merino es una app sino algún
programa de mesa que si quieren lo que
puedes posicionar a localizar el día i
y planificarlo me gusta ir antes por el
día cuando quiero hacer algo me gusta ir
a pisar el terreno sobre todo porque de
noche es muy peligroso dónde vas a pisar
no está por ejemplo la ventana de
parganas
fui por el día a comprobar y palpar y
hacer la foto con la elástica y
y la gente esto es el faro de
fuencaliente en la palma
estos son temas recurrentes que uso yo
mucho de la luna el sol la vía láctea y
siempre hay que ubicarlos y
contextualizarlo en uso
[Música]
la palma también lo impresionante no
están en fuencaliente también en la vía
lastre con un iluminado es un poquito
que pasó de un coaching y tiene el
puntito esto es en la caldera de
taburiente
cometa en medio la láctea la fotografía
nuestra fotografía es más fácil cuando
lo hacemos con grandes angulares porque
hacemos velocidad más lenta y entra todo
más fácil a medida que vamos cerrando el
as se complica la cosa y ya [ __ ] un
cometa en medio a la verdad hasta algún
objetivo total es muy complicado
esta situación aparte de hacer
fotografía lo disfruto
me encanta perderme en pasar frío no
dormir
les invito a vivir no saber que tenemos
los cielos impresionantes que cada vez
se van teniendo más y creo que
deberíamos hacer un esfuerzo por ir a
buscar estas cositas
esto es una vía láctea es un
autorretrato en el teide de las cañadas
yo solo no voy solo porque se escapó
solo estás en la playa de vargas la vía
láctea para que no lo conozca este bien
estos meses hasta el verano empieza por
el sureste amina que avanzando el año se
va poniendo vertical hasta octubre que
deja de verse si no lo han visto tampoco
se ve así desde la fotografía están
editadas pero si se ve esto es un
aerogenerador en
la salida de telefe de santa lucia
con un teleobjetivo complicado
técnicamente del mismo sitio pero por
otro lado
a otro mundo que me interesa mucho en el
tema de los aborígenes relacionados con
los calendarios astrológico esto por
ejemplo en la cueva pintada de una cueva
pintada que estaba en acusan que
entonces pensaba que tenía que ver la
vía láctea un aborigen pintada la
película noche sin punta en la con
de la vía láctea son todos corriendo de
gran canaria
en
en verano en ventaja en el solsticio de
verano que ocurre un fenómeno que gestó
el primer rayo de luz alumbra el hogar
en calle arriba del bentayga con los
guanches hacían ritos de fertilidad con
los anima guarda entonces fui a hacer
este evento en el solsticio y después
volví por la noche
no había que intentar hacer un time las
también también relacionando con el
mismo lugar en desventaja con la vía
láctea
muchas veces tú planifica fotos para
fijar la foto buena es la que los
planificados en la que la contra foto no
aquí estuve toda vez que siendo el time
las y al final de la noche
de la montañita que está allí de la
roquita y dice estas fotos que dije
estas las luces que están ahí son
nuestras luces que estamos haciendo
tres minutos
esto es una luna de verano de la cusa tú
planifican las cosas y de repente no
ajustan bien por ejemplo lo que pasó es
esto lo que yo he planificado esto y
cuando está con un con un tremendo en el
objetivo y pasa eso que haces no puedes
hacer nada no porque como toques algo
entonces pero bueno qué 2
estos otro alumno en 24 diciendo esto es
el hospital insular
nunca nos acordamos de los que pasan
entre un hospital hasta que tenemos un
familiar dentro hasta que estamos
nosotros allí pues el 24 de diciembre en
el hospital insular el pasillo se
comunica las dos edificios y estos otros
el mismo hospital un poco después las
vidas que hay un dentro del hospital
[Música]
están viendo todo es alta sensibilidad
es provocar emociones también esto es un
ensayo general
de una luna desde mi ventana también
esta es una foto tal cual hay una página
que si no conocen que es fire dar 24
horas que si no la conocen bien si
tienen miedo a volar
métanse se les quita el miedo a volar
porque en los miles de aviones que están
volando a tiempo real y tú puedes
localizarlos y lo pones entonces si
tienen ubicado esto es relativamente
fácil bueno hay que pescar lo que se
puede conseguir no esto fue el día
anterior al día siguiente cree al
eclipse
mi posición aquí no había nubes no fue
la foto que yo quería pero pero lo
conseguí
paisajes amaneceres
esta foto la planifico mi hija tengo dos
hijos de 10
qué pasa que la luna el primer tramo es
muy difícil que se vea el sol si se ve
siempre más o menos porque tienen un
tipo test para la luna el primer tramo
que hay mucha contaminación que no se ve
entonces cuando ya logré ver que no
estaba se había ido muy alto la luna
pero al día siguiente lo hice lo hice
con el sol estos al amanecer al día
siguiente
esto es en la dieta en lanzarote el
número en el primer rayito de luz es
terrible enciende los colores muy rápido
tiempo la ventana
estos desventaja un amanecer
estos grancanaria todos son estos
objetivos contenidos rápido porque esto
es un efecto también del solsticio de
invierno en desde acusa el sol sale
entre el roque nublo y ventajas del
programa origen
primer rayo de luz de este año todo el
mundo
[Risas]
este año está buscando un sitio donde
localizar el la luna del día siguiente y
también se empeña en buscar en la
alineación del roque nublo y el teide
que es un sitio complicado no se logra
ver pero bueno más o menos
la luna el día siguiente en en 24 horas
42 personas esto los resultados de mi
página con las fotos de la luna de esto
desde la ventana del 1 es la luna del 2
de enero
curiosamente aquí no se ve también la
luna justo cayó también en los
observatorios diseñé y esos son dos
fotos finales que están relacionadas de
la semana pasada no se conocen cuando
van para cadete si bien perdido mi
cristo lo único en un arbolito
utilitario y medio del paisaje en verdad
no es un arbolito solitario son dos
eucaliptos
y ese es en ese sitio y éste fue hacer
una pasada en la vía láctea con la
calima de linares
este hongo pero tal y esta foto de la
semana pasada la vía láctea natura de
las palomas nos sorprende nos
sorprenderíamos de cómo podemos ver la
vía láctea de un sitio tan céntrico tan
turístico como más valor lo que está ahí
qué está pasando
[Aplausos]
[Música]